العديد من قاده العالم والشخصيات المرموقه
توجهوا الى الجزيره الاندونيسيه بالي في
الفتره الماضيه لحضور خدمه مجموعه العشرين
لتوقظ هذه القمه جزيره بالي من سبات طويل
وتصلي الضوء على قطاع السياحه للوجه
الاستوائيه فسياحه تعد المصدر الرئيسي
للدخل في الجزيره التي تشتهر بشواطئها
الاستوائيه
الى جانب المعابد لكن هذا القطاع شهد
انتكاسه كبيره العمل الماضي فمن سته
ملايين سائح قبل الوباء انخفض عدد الصياح
الاجانب في جزيره الساحره الى بضع عشرات
فقط في 20 21 وفي اطار مساء عليها قطاع
السياحي اطلقت بالي برنامج تاشيره
للعاملين عن بعد تحت اسم تاشيره المنزل
الثاني من القرر انت تقول حيزه في ديسمبر
[موسيقى]
كما اعلنت شركه اير بي ام بي مؤخرا انها
دخلت معها في الشراكه لاستقطاب العاملين
عن بعد وحتى مع كبح فايروس كورونا من
المرجح ان يستغرق تعافي القطاع السياحي في
هذه الجزيره بعد الوقت
[موسيقى]